our goal is to have a touchless
experience you have to talk to a human
sign up single sign-on with with the
major provider
one line install script and then five
minutes you see what the potential is
that's the first aha moment
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jvengers a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opus labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today our guest is leon
cooperman this co-founder and cto of
cast ai
formerly vice president of security
products oci at oracle leon's
professional experience spends tech
companies such as ibm tuition and hosted
pci he has more than 20 years of
experience in product management
software design and development all
through production deployment and today
we're talking about cloud and really the
future of computing welcome leon
cloud computing and and
in general where we're at today we're
really at an interesting inflection
points not only do we see
so many different
organizations around the world that were
previously you know on on-premise
transitioning to the cloud but i think
that there is
a wide understanding that you know this
is what's happening and this is where
we're at and obviously covet accelerated
it and the question has become less of
should we move to the cloud it's more of
a how do we do it and how do we optimize
it and how do we manage it especially
with billing and devops etc you have
extraordinary experience and throughout
your career leading up to cast ai most
notably um
vice president of security products oci
at oracle um but but today you're a part
of a startup cast ai and i'm looking
forward to hearing a little bit about
your your own journey and how you're
seeing cloud computing
um take place today and and where we're
at and and what the opportunities are so
thank you very much for being here
hey michael thank you and that's a great
question and just to kind of give you
some context my journey was to the cloud
it was very similar to my customers
journeys to the clouds you know so you
know back 20 years ago when i was
building applications i was deploying
them in co-location data centers
at equinix and all the rest just like
everyone else was doing decades ago
right and
the last startup we did which was called
zenitch we decided because you know lack
of cap you know you don't have infinite
funding so you start with a cloud
deployment and we deployed our is a
cyber security product that we deployed
in every region of aws so i don't know
there were hot like 20 regions 30
regions whatever
and the thing so the product did well we
got really good traction
with customers and analysts and
in fact it was acquired by oracle which
you know led to a great outcome for
investors but the thing we felt
miserably on was cloud cost management i
would have this
every month me and my ceo would get into
it because we're like the bill is
exploding exponentially
i can't figure it out i i really
struggled to figure it out for a lot of
different reasons right and
at the time in the heat of battle like
we tried everything reserved instance
the savings like you name it we went
through all of those kind of pillars of
grief um and then i would say that
ultimately in that cost management
pillar we failed
and so uh
while i was at oracle i kind of saw this
recurring pattern with customers with
myself with colleagues with people that
i knew and i'm like i can't be the only
person that hasn't solved this cloud
cost infrastructure problem and it turns
out to be a massive problem it's like
the number one existential problem
for customers moving to the cloud like
if you cannot figure this part out if
there isn't a proper financial
operations environment for the cloud we
will see backwards movement we'll see
repatriation to data centers
and so if we're looking at taking a step
back and we're looking at billing
and and how cloud has changed the way
customers think through billing whether
it's the
the timeline the ability to
to predict um the costs associated how
is building today different from you
know building perhaps 15 years ago or or
what you know how does this change the
way people are are dealing with consumer
behavior with billing as we transition
to the cloud
michael have you ever seen an aws build
like you literally have to be a rocket
scientist to dissect that thing but
that's not the main problem like you
could hire some really smart actuaries
to figure out the bill the problem is
who holds the keys to the kingdom
15 years ago how did you build a data
center well you have to go and ask for a
bunch of money it was capital
expenditure or capex so you would say
here give me 5 million bucks i'll go
build this out and three data centers
right the financial team had to sign off
on that
the operating expenses were predictable
and known because they were multi-year
contracts with whoever your providers
were the bandwidth provider the data
center provider et cetera et cetera but
that completely flipped on its head and
for good reason the business said
you know boards and ceos said look we
want faster innovation so we're going to
give the keys to the innovators to the
engineers and
we're going to figure out the financial
part out there and it looked like a
better opex model operational expense
right so we'll just pay for what we use
engineers will order
infrastructure and services and when
they don't need them they'll shut them
down and the world is a great happy
place the problem is is engineers don't
care about the costs of the resources
they order they're not it's not one of
their kpis or any of their kpis they're
not financially trained right they just
want to get the engineering job done and
that's the fundamental
shift in thought process it's who is
making the decision
and it's not the financial folks
therefore you're going to have very lax
financial controls and you've seen this
across all industries now where
everyone's been hit with a bill
unexpected and now they're scratching
their head to figure out processes to
fix it
so
what i'm hearing from you is that
there's there's a few factors here that
are contributing to
to a new situation in which
people are uncomfortable right there's a
lack of control there's a transition of
control
and
now there and what with the transition
of control there's there weren't really
processes in place to manage it
and to maintain that same sort of
rigorous thinking and that same behavior
from a company's perspective
in the new world where now engineers are
perhaps in control they have the keys
and and at the end the technology is
what drives the company right and and so
it's it's hard to argue not to not to
consume these deployments
but why
so what do we do at that point i mean is
the solution do you think to to regain
the control to those that are you know
in the higher management and the ones
that previously were holding the keys or
is it to change the way that we think
through cloud
billing well what what are the different
solutions we can present here
yeah so
uh the control the solution is not to
give
not to create a bunch of gates uh for
financial folks to
have to approve everything that's just
not gonna that'll completely stifle
innovation and it reduces the promise of
cloud entirely right so right we might
as well go back to data centers the
there is a new kind of breed of of job
in in startup world and in sas and he's
starting to proliferate through other
organizations called fintech so uh sorry
thin ops kin ops is the process of
understanding your technology operations
in the context of the of the bill and
i've started like even like government
agencies have started to create a
thin-ups
position in their groups
so the idea there is is you have an
engineering-minded person that tries to
understand but michael i there was a
step in between where people said we'll
solve this with better reporting let us
do tagging tagging is a common practice
in cloud to basically label resources
for different departments and uses so
that you can generate a cost report that
is meaningful per department or per team
and then so there's a whole wave of
companies like uh cloudhealth and many
many others that uh were all eventually
acquired that just generated reports the
problem with the reports is nobody takes
the if there's a recommendation no one
will take it because if you are an
engineer and you're responsible for a
service and you have to get it up in the
middle of the night if it breaks are you
going to risk taking a
operation that has potentially
destabilizing effect but because you're
reducing resources that may or may not
be needed you're not sure right so
reports are not the answer and they're
kind of an intermediate step we needed
to get to in evolution here's the answer
the answer is automation right we don't
have enough engineers period in the
world like we're completely short of of
engineers less engineers that can speak
uh cloud
dialects of aws google azure etc
world is kind of moving to a
containerized modern application
structure
of microservices
and so there's a whole cloud native
movement another set of
uh engineering learning requirements
you're putting on these teams so by
cloud native i'm specifically referring
to the
container kubernetes ecosystem
so the answer is automation and that's
what we're focused on we're like we're
going to give you some reports to show
you how you're doing but the main thing
we're trying to do is make sure you're
not overspending systematically through
machine driven optimizations all of the
time so the cast solution makes a
decision every 15 seconds on every
cluster that it operates against you
need to add capacity to roof capacity we
need to swap capacity do we need the bin
pack what do we need to do to bring this
cluster into its optimal shape
without sacrificing service level
objectives and i i believe that's the
final goal is the autonomous operations
of these low-level systems
so i'm hearing that the thesis that that
you've come up with is that consumer
behavior is changing the world is
changing we're not going back to data
centers we have to
make do with the fact that
you know today the engineers innovation
runs the company and we need to allow
for you know engineers and any engineer
in the organization to perhaps deploy
cluster and and go about their testing
and about their their
everything they're doing
engineering-wise but
the key here is to actually do the
optimizations to reduce the spending and
to reduce the cloud and yes the you know
transparency and observability are
important traits but really it's the
technology that allows you to actually
optimize on your bill and that is you
know cluster based instance based and
it's not
restructuring
the operations of who decides how much
money to spend and where yeah because if
you have that automation to put in place
it's easily
it's easy to create some role-based
access
to
create those controls and structures
like the report can go to the financial
guy now the right person on the devops
team can make the decisions for what how
heavily to optimize like what is the
what does that progress bar look like
and i'll give you just a couple of
examples michael like you know most
devops engineers when they create a
cluster they pick a computer type and
instance type in the cloud that they've
worked with that they know best oh i'll
use the m5 series because i've been
using it for the last three years great
well
they're not experts on all these other
lifecycles do they have reserved
instances do they have savings plans
that the finance team has already booked
are there spot instances available that
are tolerant to their workloads spot
instances are these things that can get
taken away very abruptly but maybe your
workload is super tolerant as a
microservice so they're not experts on
all of these cloud financial terms so
when our when we come in the first thing
that we do when we analyze a cluster and
anyone can do this by the way it's the
free service that we offer um you can
just sign up and do it
we tell you like you're using these
instances they're not actually optimal
for these and these reasons you know you
have memory heavy memory recovery um
workloads you need to kind of skew to
this way and then we give you the
the outcome of that analysis which you
can just go implement yourself but
that's a point in time implementation
you know you're going to drift
immediately like a couple hours later
your requirements are going to change
that's why it's so important to have
automation because
the minute you optimize yourself you
will be out of sync within a couple of
hours
right i mean it kind of sounds like
going to rent a car and you're so used
to your five-seater toyota corolla
but but now you're just coming alone
perhaps and you know maybe that's not
what you need but you take it out of
comfort because that's what you know and
you know that it works but maybe you're
still paying seven times what you would
pay if you actually used what you needed
now if you're looking at
cast ai today in the landscape in the
cloud landscape walk me through
your interaction with you know the
consumer behavior of how you know from
from somebody who identifies cast ai as
a potential opportunity for their
company what is sort of the process that
they go through until they reach that
aha moment of okay i'm actually gaining
value from this
they're kind of two
schools of consumer behavior the
consumer that is already looking for a
solution and the consumer that doesn't
know he has a problem and they're both
really interesting journeys right so
we're we're entering a potential shift
in economic
like outcome in the world like we might
have slowed down and we remember michael
we've experienced growth for the last 10
15 years non-stop right so everyone has
just been adding fuel to the fire
cost controls haven't been the number
one thing on top of boards and ceo's
minds lately right but what i'm seeing
since we started casting and maybe it
took us six months to kind of have the
world catch up is people are now saying
okay
if we're going to go enter a slowdown
we're going to have to show some gross
margin improvement we're going to have
to show
some cost controls where am i spending
all my money and to give you an example
like a company like snapchat a third of
their revenue goes to cloud spend that's
third and that's in the billions of
dollars right so imagine you know like
that's the most sophisticated user of
cloud
where you know where that lies in the
spectrum so for those personas for those
people who are looking for a solution
already they tend to find us because if
they're kubernetes users so like if you
have a general workload and you haven't
modernized your app we're not for you
and we probably wouldn't find our
solution but if you're a kubernetes user
you'll probably find our solution and
our goal is to have a touchless
experience you have to talk to a human
sign up single sign-on with with the
major provider
one line install script and then five
minutes you see what the potential is
that's the first aha moment then it's
the too good to be true moment let me
call someone and figure out where the vs
is right and that's when we get involved
we have a sales engineering team and an
an account executive team they get
involved they we walk our customers
through the process and we usually do a
proof of concept we don't want to charge
anyone any money if there's not going to
be value there so we say okay look let's
do a two week poc we're going to onboard
your pre-prod or your broad clusters
we're going to show you the savings
we're you know we'll show you the money
from that movie uh with jerry maguire
and then we end up doing a commercial
deal after it so that's kind of like the
first persona and then the second
persona is
when they we have customers that see the
savings report and the reaction is like
i actually didn't know i needed a
solution until i saw this like i didn't
realize how much money i'm wasting right
those are a little bit harder to get
because they're harder to like you don't
know you have a problem why are you
gonna take a phone call or or like a
zoom meeting right
sure right if we're looking now at you
know where we're headed and we're
obviously we're talking about the
consumer behavior that's shifted in the
last few years pretty dramatically and
and so i can only imagine you know where
the world holds for us do you feel like
we we've reached sort of you know and
this this is the new evolution of how
you know
tech companies are working our companies
in general are managing their data and
their innovation this is it or or do you
expect that we're going to have some
more dramatic changes that we need to
that we need to account for
yeah so i think a lot of it depends on
like the current
technology the like delivery model that
companies are in like there's a big
movement for continuous integration
continuous delivery it's typically
called ci cd
but not a lot of companies are there
what i mean by that is they use the
tools but they release once a week or
once a month like i mean for me that is
a terrible way of building software like
it's a way we built software 20 years
ago we were 30 years ago when we shipped
it so i think that transformation has to
happen fully and we have to enter
everyone has to understand the service
team model which i don't think everyone
does
this and by the service team model i
kind of define it as a small team of
five to 12 people that are specifically
responsible for a set of micro services
but they're responsible for everything
they're responsible for
the way the service is designed the
requirements the way it's built the way
it's deployed all of the devops tasks
all the way deploying it in production
and then monitoring it and being on call
and my theory around this is if you're
going to be on call for a service you're
going to be a lot more careful about how
you write the code and you're going to
make sure it's covered in tests properly
that transition has to happen and we're
not fully there we still have silos of
qa teams and sre teams and
i think those are all going to be
collapsed into a single engineering
framework um that's kind of one big
trend that i see michael
where where are you in all this
in the world of
cloud in the world of you know the of
optimization that you know anything that
has it with what you're doing where
where are you in the center of it and
and why
why sp why are you spending so much time
in your career on these problems
yeah so like this is a kind of a passion
project for me
and there's a couple of issues that i
really hate about the cloud that have to
get solved right and so my goal
is to is to solve them like before i
make my exit stage left uh exit stage
left so one of them is um
vendor lock-in i really don't like the
fact the way that clouds are locking
customers i i understand why they're
doing it but i don't like it and there's
a couple of artificial barriers that
need to be broken one of them is data
gravity i am super passionate about this
you can ship as much data as you want to
any of the big clouds for free they'll
even ship you an appliance and say load
it all up on these ssds and we'll load
it up for you and you're not going to
pay a penny but if you ever want to get
your data out you're done it's hotel
california like check out
any time you want but you're never going
anywhere because it's too expensive to
go anywhere so
it's an artificial barrier they charge
money for egress that they shouldn't be
charging it's a monopolistic behavior
that i want to see come to an end and
that's
that will give customers the freedom to
move between infrastructures or have
multiple infrastructures
that freeing up of the world is only
going to lead to greater growth so i
think these clouds are getting in their
own way
artificially and i want to help the
world kind of see the light on that yeah
and then the second piece is we are so
short
on people and resources and i think
we're getting to a point in our supply
chain crunch where
we are getting to the point where
moore's law is going to fail like
you you're familiar with the 18 so the
idea here is is the computing power
doubles every 18 months therefore cost
should have ever 18 months that's only
logical right number of nips produced
but if all of your semiconductor
innovation is centered in taiwan and you
have all of these supply chain issues
and this is kind of where i'm spending a
lot of time writing and researching
right now michael
what happens if taiwan goes away and we
can't get the next generation of micron
slimming improvements like we can't get
those wafers any smaller for three to
five more years because we're busy
scrambling for just to keep up with car
shortages and never mind data centers um
we are going to have a slow down or a
severe inflection in moore's law and
that's going to lead to price increases
not decreases so there
through automation i believe we can
solve all this by doing better with the
resources we have and by the way when
you shrink a customer's footprint when
you shrink their bill you're doing one
really amazing thing they're shrinking
the amount of electricity they use the
cooling that they use the water waste is
generated et cetera et cetera so
overall we don't need to be spewing
wasted energy into the environment that
doesn't need to be wasted it's just a
better use of the resources we have
today
i love it
all in all it sounds like a fascinating
world it sounds like a fascinating
problem that you're tackling and really
an enabler for companies to continue
innovating and and creating really
meaningful products and
and then i and i can't wait to try it
out myself and and what i really like is
the sort of the holistic view of cloud
and where we're headed and understanding
the the shift in consumer behavior
and and where we're at so leon i really
want to thank you it's been a pleasure i
really appreciate your time and and your
energy and the insights and thank you
for the inspiration and best of luck
with cast ai and stay safe and stay
healthy thank you very much
[Music]